this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
it is more important to know what sort
of person has a disease
than to know what sort of disease a
person has so hello and welcome to the
cheeky science show where as reflected
in that famous quote by hippocrates
we'll be taking a look in this video at
precision medicine
and the promises of improving health by
accounting for individual variability
in genes environment and lifestyle in
particular we'll be focusing on
seven opportunities that can accelerate
precision medicine as reflected in this
recent commentary article in cell
and discuss how this can be applied to
individuals to help them improve their
health for as long as possible
but we'll also take a look at some of
the challenges still ahead and how those
challenges can be tackled
so first then what is precision medicine
well it will help to give an example
last year the national institutes of
health nutrition research task force
announced that they had initiated a
strategic plan
for 2030 for achieving precision
nutrition
and this is the idea that answering the
question what should we eat to stay
healthy
is not a very simple question to answer
and this is because the answer is not a
one size fits all
and each of us have individual dietary
responses and so precision nutrition is
aiming to provide
individualized actionable dietary
recommendations
that can help us to decide what when why
and how to eat to optimize our health
and quality of life
so extending the same principles back to
precision medicine
the aims of precision medicine is to be
able to refine diagnoses
provide more rational treatment options
with the overall aim in preventing
diseases
and this is reflected in the name
precision medicine with higher precision
referring to the fact that more relevant
results are achieved then are relevant
ones
although i do hope that it's also
accurate not just precise
and so you may have also come across
this term as personalized medicine
but they all pretty much mean the same
thing tailoring the input and output
data
to an individual so what will it take to
achieve precision medicine by 2030
well in this recent article there are
seven key opportunities that are
outlined
as we'll now discuss the first
opportunity are the development of huge
longitudinal cohorts and so this is to
build upon the work that's already been
conducted
over the last two decades including
national cohorts
such as the uk battery bank and the all
of us
research program that have generated
these huge populations with genomic
laboratory and lifestyle assessments as
well as longitudinal follow-ups
on health outcomes and so basically
there's already a wealth of information
that's already out there but to make
this data more accessible
what's really needed are ways in which
all of the information from these
different cohorts
can be merged together to make it easier
for different researchers to access
and so this would involve the
development of common data models and
file formats to facilitate collaboration
and interoperability
but the good news is that efforts are
already being undertaken to improve this
process
such as work conducted by the global
alliance for genomics and health
the second opportunity is improved
diversity and inclusion in science
and so shockingly less than three
percent of the participants in published
genome-wide association studies
are of african hispanic or latin
american ancestries and 86
of clinical trial participants are white
so there is much room for improvement
which is very much needed if we can
reduce the risks of exacerbating health
disparities
moreover by improving diversity in these
studies it will enable
better biological discoveries and as
stated in this article it extends from
just
the involvement in research studies but
also to
improve the diversity of the biomedical
research workforce
as with a more diverse workforce in
culture ancestry beliefs
scientific backgrounds and
methodological approaches
it will improve the understanding
innovation trust
and cultural sensitivity with the
ultimate aim of delivering better
research which i think we can all agree
is of highest priority so the third
opportunity is big data and artificial
intelligence
and if you've read eric topol's book
deep medicine you'll know that
artificial intelligence is going to be
so important for integrating all of
these big data sets
in terms of delivering precision
medicine and out of these different
artificial intelligence approaches
deep machine learning and deep neural
networks will play an important role in
being able to integrate
the different layers of information that
can be gathered for each individual
and so as you can see in the schematic
of a deep neural network
taken from eric's book there are
multiple different
input layers that can be taken from an
individual
and by integrating this information into
a deep neural network it can provide an
output of virtual health guidance
and so deep neural networks are
particularly suited for these kind of
data sets
where there are multiple hidden layers
between the input and output layers
with the models being able to extract
complex dependencies in the data
and select features that are most
relevant to predictions
and so another situation where this
could be really useful is
being able to predict biological age
with the idea of inputting information
from different biomarkers of age
with their network using that
information to accurately predict
age and so these networks are initially
trained on
current biological data and then to
improve the accuracy this process is
iterative
in that the network can be improved over
time so with more data to begin with the
better the network can learn
to further improve the accuracy of the
output the inputs are also very
important
and that includes not only what inputs
are used but also the quality of those
inputs
with higher quality data inputs being
desirable
and so that brings us on to the next
couple of opportunities which talk more
about what these inputs are going to be
and so the next opportunity is routine
clinical genomics to guide prevention
diagnosis and therapy and so currently
genomics
so that means sequencing the dna of an
individual is primarily limited to
rare diseases and select cancers to make
rational treatment decisions based on
their genetic information
however by 2030 the authors of this
commentary
predict that genomics will be routine
with genetic causes and targeted
therapies being discovered for many
common diseases
and also microbiome measurements being
routinely included
in part this will become possible due to
the ever-declining costs
in sequencing dna and the reason that
this could be useful
is that it's because all of us have
different genetic variations
and this means that we could respond
differently to different drugs
and so this is where pharmacogenomics
comes in which is effectively genomics
guided therapies
that can improve drug efficacy reduce
adverse effects and also reduce cost
by tailoring the therapy to the
individual based on their genetic
information
but this is just one layer of
information and so this leads onto the
next opportunity
which is higher variety higher
resolution phenomics and environmental
exposure data
for both clinical and research use so
effectively what this next
opportunity is referring to is the
continued growth of research and
clinical uses
for different ways to measure clinical
phenotypes exposures and lifestyle
and basically try to harness the pretty
much unlimited
biological physiological anatomical and
environmental data
that could be very valuable for
improving the output data
and it's important to also note that the
data for an individual is going to vary
on a daily weekly
seasonal yearly basis and more on from
that
since the majority of our lives are
spent outside the healthcare system
it's going to be the integration of
wearable devices
and offer patient provided information
that are going to be able to
augment this aspect and going back to
the example we used earlier of precision
nutrition
it could be by 2030 that instead of
using dietary assessments
based on research surveys instead data
could be linked with grocery stores
digital uploads from restaurants or
machine learning applied to food imaging
to provide more feasible
comprehensive capture of dietary habits
so where is all this information going
to be stored for an individual
well this brings us on to the next
opportunity which is the use of
electronic health records
as a source of phenomic and genomic
research now electronic health records
are not new
and are already extensively used however
at the moment they're only episodic
captures from healthcare without robust
genomic support
moreover the data is pretty much not
portable in terms of being able to
integrate it
with different health records and so by
2030 the hope is that
the electronic health records will not
only be gname and device enabled
but that the data can be easily moved
between electronic health records
and to participants apps and so this
brings us on to the last and
what i think is probably the most
important opportunity discussed in this
article
which is privacy participant trust and
returning value and so what this last
opportunity
is talking about is the fact that the
utility of precision medicine
very much depends on there being broad
participation
but to have broad participation of a
large population
it requires trust from individuals
protection of privacy
and a return of value to those
participants and so in many ways this is
possibly
one of the hardest challenges of
achieving precision medicine
given the fact that science has not
always been trustworthy or honored all
participants equally
so let's hope that with increased
transparency and authentic engagement
with communities
this can improve trust and create
participant advocates and ensure a more
thoughtful
culturally sensitive direction and in
terms of being able to keep the data
secure and private it seems very likely
that access control
via blockchain and the use of hashed
identifiers to be able to link the data
and other encryption processes to be
able to analyze the data
will definitely play a key role but
there are still many other challenges
that aren't addressed in this article
for example it would be very important
for there to be evidence that precision
medicine is actually working
and for that to happen we would need
randomized controlled trials
to show that the outcomes in terms of
the patient's health has been improved
by using these different approaches
and we'll run from that it's important
to be able to identify
why there's false positives or so-called
incidental findings
whereby these deep neural networks give
abnormal readings
and so whilst we can come back to the
point of improving the
outputs by improving the quality of the
input data
that doesn't necessarily solve the issue
given the fact that
improving the measurement doesn't
automatically lead to improved prognosis
and diagnosis for example the
introduction of the stethoscope
was seen as a great advance due to the
allowance for more precise detection and
classification of heart murmurs among
hospitalized patients
however this led to problems when some
individuals with detected heart murmurs
were advised against doing physical
labor and had to pay more for medical
insurance
without having established firm
knowledge about the relation
between such signs and symptomatic heart
problems and since most of these
patients never developed heart problems
the example illustrates how introduction
of prognostic technologies can
unintentionally lead to harm if bodily
signs are over-interpreted as
indications of future disease however
the iteration and updates of these deep
neural networks may be able to
circumvent this
and then the final point to consider is
to what extents does someone have
control over the giving of their
information
and also the freedom in terms of acting
upon the suggested advice
now i don't think there's any simple
answers to these questions
and ultimately they require much
discussion but they should not be
ignored as the development of precision
medicine becomes closer
so all in all there is much promise for
precision medicine
with real-time accurate predictive
valuable guidance to promote health span
for each individual however as we've
discussed there are also many challenges
to achieving precision medicine by 2030
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video longevity
technology for which i am very grateful
longevity technology deliver high
quality daily news and insights on
research
investments and technologies that extend
health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description so i hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening